LEIGHA JARETT: Hi, everybody.
My name is Leigha Jarett, and
I'm a product demonstrations
manager at Looker.
Today, I'm going to be talking
about how our customers here
at Google Cloud have
been using data powered
by BigQuery and Looker to
make data-driven responses
to COVID-19.
I'm going to start by
talking about the impetus
for creating this data block
that I'll go into in a bit.
I'm going to talk about how
our customers were coming to us
and needed to analyze
all this publicly
available data for COVID-19.
And then I'm going to jump into
a very quick overview of Looker
and BigQuery just to give you
context on the different tools
we're using.
Next, I'm going to walk through
the actual marketplace block
that Looker team has
launched with the BigQuery
public datasets team.
And last, I'm going to
talk through a couple
of our customers' stories,
and how they've actually used
the marketplace block
that we've created
to make data-driven responses.
So, like I said, we began
getting a lot of requests
from our customers asking how
they can use our tools here
at Google Cloud to
actually analyze
all the data that was becoming
available from COVID-19.
As a product demonstrations
manager at Looker,
I'm responsible for creating
different demonstrations of how
we can use Looker to
analyze various data sets.
So many people on our team
were reaching out to me asking,
how do we create a demo to
show how we can actually
use Looker in BigQuery to
analyze all of this data?
We were getting requests from
all different industries.
We had government
offices contacting us
who needed data to understand
how they can create
different policies and state
mitigations to better limit
the spread of the disease.
We had different health
care institutions
that were coming to our
sales teams and our engineers
asking how they could
use data to prepare
for an influx of cases
across the world.
And, of course, we had all
of our other businesses--
e-commerce companies,
real estate companies--
all asking us, how
can we really make
use of all the data
that's become available
and join it back
with our own data
so we can make
insightful decisions
and better prepare our
businesses for what's
happening in the world?
At the start of COVID-19,
different institutions
started releasing data.
You could hop on Google and see
tons of different data sources.
Different companies, various
biomedical institutions,
and universities
were all coming out
with publicly
available data sets
showing both testing
rates and infection
rates across the world.
It was really overwhelming
amount of data.
So our customers
were continuously
coming to us trying to figure
out what data sources to use,
how to use these data sources.
And to make matters
more confusing,
each data source had
its own definitions
with its own schema.
So it was really difficult to
understand where do we start?
What data sources do we use?
And then what do we actually
do with those data sources?
So just want to
make a quick note
about the BigQuery
public datasets program.
The BigQuery public
datasets program
took a large amount of these
different data sources,
created definitions so you
clearly understood what
those data sources,
where they came from,
what the metrics meant.
And, of course, they take
care of all of that ETL, the
getting the data into the actual
database for you each day,
so that all of our
BigQuery customers
can simply query this
data and have it available
without needing to figure
out what data sources
they should use and
how they could get it
into their own databases.
The problem with
using this data set
is our analysts at all of
our customers still needed
to figure out what
to do with this data.
And they also had to create the
queries directly in BigQuery
to get answers to
their own questions.
So, of course, a
query is a database
that Google Cloud
powers, but you really
need to understand SQL in order
to be able to ask questions
of this data.
A lot of our customers
have analysts
who are familiar with
using SQL, but that
means we're limiting who
actually can ask questions
of the data, and we really
need that technical resource
to be the person who's
going in and asking
the questions for us.
This is where a Looker comes in.
And just to give everyone a
bit of background on Looker
if you don't already know,
Looker is a data platform,
and it's going to fit directly
on top of your SQL database.
So in this case, we're
talking about sitting directly
on top of our public data
sets available in BigQuery.
Now, Looker is powered by a
Git version-controlled modeling
layer that we call LookML.
What LookML allows us
to do is actually create
a data dictionary of all
of our different metrics.
We use raw SQL to define
those calculations.
And then business
users, folks who
are not familiar with
writing SQL queries can
jump in into the Looker
platform, slice and dice data,
create new reports, export
the data, schedule it.
Basically, they're
empowered to go in and ask
new questions of this data
without needing to rely
on a technical resource.
This was also really
important for us,
because like I mentioned
before, the data that
was published with COVID-19 was
not exactly straightforward.
We had different companies
that were defining
metrics in different ways.
We had data that
was getting updated
at different frequencies.
And putting this all together,
we had a whole team of analysts
here at Looker trying to work
on creating that LookML modeling
layer to look at the
metrics related to COVID-19.
So to give you a little
bit of background,
we had, you know, maybe 10
or 15 of our sales engineers
jumping in, reading
up on that data,
learning the data sources,
understanding the calculations
that were coming out on
places like "New York Times"
or for Johns Hopkins.
And we were creating
our own LookML model
to look at those calculations--
things like number
of new cases that
were emerging each day, daily
growth rates, average growth
rates across different regions.
And we had a pretty
robust process
for going through
our calculations,
testing things,
making sure everything
was working appropriately.
Now, of course, we did all
this to basically create
these product demonstrations
to show our customers, hey,
this is how you can
actually analyze this data.
But after going
through this effort,
we realized we should
make this model that we've
created available to
all of our customers
so that they don't have to
go through this same process
that we just went through.
This is where Looker's
Marketplace comes into play.
Looker's Marketplace is
an in-app marketplace.
So on your Looker instance,
you can go up, go directly
into the Marketplace, and
install what we call "blocks."
These blocks are really just
pre-built pieces of LookML,
so that SQL-based modeling
layer, that can help you
be making data decisions,
data-driven decisions faster.
What I mean by this is we don't
want our customers spending all
their time trying to understand
what the different data sets
mean, where they're coming from,
how often things are updated,
when they're calculated.
We want our customers to
be actually using the data
to make those data-driven
decisions for their business,
because that's what
they're best at doing.
So our team, after
creating this LookML model,
we decided to publish it
into the Looker Marketplace.
What this means for
our customers is anyone
could go into the
Marketplace, click a button,
download the Marketplace block
into their local instance,
and have our model that
we've created available
for them to use, so that
they're really accelerating
their time to value when it
came to these public data sets.
So when our customers go
and install this block
into their Looker
instance, they're
going to get a few things.
First off, they're going
to get two dashboards that
are international dashboards.
One, on the left-hand
side, is where
you can see an
international view of what's
happening across the world.
This data is primarily powered
by Johns Hopkins and "The New
York Times" and some
other data sources
that show things like testing
or government decisions.
On the right-hand side,
we can see a dashboard
that's focused on Italy.
Now, this is because the
Italian government published
a few different data sets that
talk in-depth about the case
spread across Italy.
Next, we have two
other dashboards that
focus on the United States.
First, we have a view of the
entire United States where
we can see things like hospital
bed utilization and infection
rates across the country.
From here, we can drill down
into a brand new dashboard
which focuses on a single
state, and it shows you
all the way down to
county-level information.
We're also able to see what the
mitigation and policy response
has been for that state.
And, of course, we can change
filters to only narrow down
to look at a couple of
counties within that state
or compare multiple
states with each other.
One other thing I
wanted to mention
is that more recently,
we've decided
to publish another block
into the Marketplace focused
on the mobility data that's
been published by Google.
This data talks about
patterns in mobility
across the United States.
And with both of these blocks
installed on your Looker
instance, you can see
this data side by side
and get a clear view of
how mobility patterns have
been correlated with
different infection
spread across the country.
Now, when you
download this block
into your Looker instance,
you get those dashboards.
But even better is you have the
Explore environment to actually
go and slice and dice the data
and ask brand new questions.
As I mentioned before,
any business user
can hop in and ask
these questions,
while Looker is simply
compiling that SQL query
and sending it back to
the query on your behalf.
Now, we notice that this
information can be confusing.
And since it's such
sensitive data,
it's really important
for us to make sure
that our customers understand
exactly what these numbers mean
and how they were calculated.
That's why here, you can
see some screenshots I've
taken where you have all
the different tool tips that
show descriptions of how
the metrics are calculated,
descriptions of what
kind of questions
you can ask in this
data-exploration environment,
and links to all
the data sources
so you can go
directly to the source
and understand things like how
they've collected the data.
And last, of course, you got
that Looker modeling layer
that's powering this
entire experience.
Like I mentioned, that modeling
layer acts as a data dictionary
where we basically have
this dictionary of all
of our metrics that are powering
both the Explore environment,
and they're powering
those dashboards.
But what's really interesting
about Marketplace blocks
and Looker is that you can
actually extend the block,
and you can change the
actual base configuration, so
modify that data dictionary,
so that it fits your needs.
And better yet, you can
extend it and join it
back on with your own data.
And this is the real
power of this block.
And this is kind of our impetus
for releasing a block like this
is we want you and
all of our customers
to join it back on your data
so you can get increased
insights into what's
really happening
and how it's affecting
your business specifically.
So I hope that after
this presentation,
you're going to go
ahead and check out
the Looker Marketplace.
We have a lot of
documentation available on how
you can use these blocks
and how you can modify them
for your own needs.
Additionally, we
wanted to make sure
that you clearly understand how
the modeling layer is working.
So we had our team
of sales engineers
go in and write clear
documentation, robust comments
to really make sure that you're
understanding each calculation
that's performed.
Now what I want to talk about
is a couple of our customers
who are actually using
this block that we built
to help them make decisions
for their business
during this difficult time.
The first I want to
talk about is HCA.
And HCA is one of the nation's
leading health care providers.
At the start of
COVID, they came to us
with a goal of creating a
national response portal.
The goal of this
national response portal
was to give health care
administrators and government
officials a single
place to monitor
the spread of this
disease across the country
so that they can make
better informed decisions
on both hospital administration
tasks like staffing
and utilization of resources
and also for our government
officials to be making
data-informed decisions
on policies.
So HCA worked with one
of our partners, SADA,
to build out this portal that
any of the nation's providers
can opt in to and also
contribute data to.
What's really powerful
about what HCA did
is they took the data
that we had worked
with in our block, all this
publicly available data that's
in BigQuery.
But they went
ahead and joined it
on their own proprietary
data from these hospitals.
This data centered around things
like ventilator and ICU bed
utilization so that hospitals
can log in at any moment,
focus on one geography,
and see real-time analytics
about what's going on in
that area and, of course,
make better plans for the
future based on the information
that they're seeing.
Now, although COVID-19 was what
inspired this national response
portal to be created, HCA
hopes that this will live on,
because obviously,
this framework is going
to be really important for
other diseases and just
general public health.
The next customer I'm going to
talk about is Diamond Resorts.
I'm sure many of you have
heard of Diamond Resorts.
They're a timeshare
company with vacation spots
around the whole world.
When the pandemic
hit, I'm sure you all
realize that travel
and leisure was
one of the industries that was
hit hardest from the beginning.
People were probably
nervous to travel.
And, of course, there
were restrictions
being placed on where
you could travel,
where you were going to, and
where you could come from.
So Diamond Resorts had
an influx of requests
coming from their customers
about rescheduling
their vacations,
canceling their vacations.
And Diamond Resorts
really needed a way
to adapt to this
influx of requests.
So what they did was they
used this block as well
and used Looker to analyze
this COVID-19 data, analyze it
alongside their own data
around who is rescheduling,
who's canceling, and tried
to predict when are people
going to want to reschedule?
Where will they be
rescheduling their trips?
And basically, use all
this information to plan
appropriately so that they're
helping their customers get
through this difficult
time and ensure
that they'll be able to
reschedule these vacations when
it's safe to do so and where
and when they want to go.
The last customer I'm going
to talk about today is Garten.
And Garten delivers
healthy food and snacks
to offices around the country.
So, of course, you can imagine
that when offices shut down
in most of the major cities
in the United States,
Garten needed a way to
adapt to this change.
Now that things are
beginning to reopen
or we see changes
in our society,
Garten needed a way to basically
plan for this reopening
and try to understand what
offices would be reopening,
what capacity would
they be reopening at?
Would they have half of their
employees coming back to work?
Would they only have a handful?
And basically, come
up with programs
that are going to support
these offices as we're going
through this influx of changes.
So Garten went ahead and they
used the Looker block as well.
And just like the other
companies I talked about,
they were able to look at this
data alongside their own data
around what customers they
have, how many employees
these customers have, where
they are in the United States,
and basically come up
with those programs
to fulfill their
customers' needs.
So I just want to take
time to say thank you
all for joining us here
today and listening to how
our customers are using all
this technology and data to make
these data-driven responses.
I really encourage you
to go understand more
about BigQuery public datasets
program, also, the Looker
Marketplace.
And you can find really useful
information about this block
that we've created in this
link that I've posted here.
One of our friends
here a Looker has
decided to create
a blog post that
goes into detail
on why we decided
to create this block, what
data we used for our block,
and also has a link to a
publicly accessible dashboard
and Explore environment
so that if you want
to be able to analyze
the data yourself,
you can go to this website
and create your own reports,
drill into data, get a feel for
what you would be experiencing
with Looker.
So thank you.